all right I was asked to give a little
bit of more of an advanced tutorial so I
will not go into the big like the center
stuff of sapphic etiquette learn how to
build a model that much I want to do a
quick review of that and then go into
some more advanced specialized things so
I put some material online with some
notebooks if you want to follow along
the slides at least as an OpenOffice
presentation are also online but it's
mostly gonna be slides this time
actually and sorry I'm so but jet lagged
also have metal staples in my head that
don't help my concentration so a lot
about myself I would did a PhD at
University of Bonn and machine learning
computer vision then I went to Amazon
machine learning where the computer
vision applications in forecasting and
now at the NYU at central cosines who I
work on so I could learn more or less
full-time so as you are all please feel
free to interrupt me at any point so the
idea is that you learn something about
cycle learn so if something I'm saying
is unclear please interrupt me so ii
learn as you probably know is machine
learning library in Python that has a
lot of algorithms for different machine
learning tasks like classification
regression clustering and so on but and
it additionally has stuff to do model
selection a grid search and
cross-validation model evaluation things
and yeah a lot of and pipelining
features pre-processing
to build home modeling pipelines it's a
pretty big open source community around
scikit-learn so there's around like 20
core developers depending on how you
count there's for each release between
100 and hundred 50 people contribute
pretty much I'm pretty sure some of them
are in the room for the last release
all right so and so here's what I was
sort of what I'm gonna talk about in
this verse so first basic concepts
working with text data then more
advanced model building evaluation out
of core learning which will touch on
some of the stuff that we talked about
yesterday who here who in this room was
at a meet-up yesterday not that many
okay so it's not too bad and then new
stuff in 0:17 which is the current
stable release and as your 18 def which
will be the next release in the next
month or two months I don't know all
right so maybe just so for me to
calibrate how many people here have used
scikit-learn okay how many people you
have not used so I could learn huh so I
was asked to do an advanced tutorial
sorry for the people that have not used
scikit-learn things might be a little
bit too quick but I try to cover the
basic principles so whether you follow
along or not it's always good to look at
a documentation we have a lot of
documentation particularly on second
learner orc in particular what I find
most helpful is the user guide which has
narrative like explaining all the
algorithms and how they work and an API
documentation which explains what all
the different parameters are what all
the functions are and so on so user
guide gives a little bit more of a big
picture an API gives all the details of
ten augmentations there's also examples
which are also helpful I think so
obviously if you do machine learning we
need some data the way we represent data
first I could learn is as a two
dimensional numpy array or sockeye
sparse matrix and we so for all of this
talk I assume everything is numeric and
that's the interface that most of a
cycle learn has so you have
floating-point numbers each sample is
one row in your mate in your
two-dimensional array and each feature
so one particular property is one column
so let's say it's row is one user for
which you want to predict whether I
click on something and
one column is I don't know their age or
gender or whatever and then you have
some output which are if you do
supervised learning which are for
classification discrete labels or for
regression like continuous values and
I'll always call these X 4 is a two
dimensional data array and Y is the
one-dimensional array of targets and I
will always use these letters so then to
do like basic supervised learning all
the machine learning algorithms and
cycle learn whether supervised or
unsupervised are all implemented in
Python classes so what you do to use any
algorithm is you instantiate a class
that Slayers say a random forest
classifier here
this skill F object code has the methods
to build a model to apply the model and
all the parameters of the model
everything is estimated from the data
will be stored in a CLF object so this
encapsulates the whole model and how it
is applied you build all the models
using the fit function so I give the fit
function my training data X train and
these are training outputs y train if
this would be for classification or
regression and they build a model here
the random forest and store them in the
CLF object if I want to use the model to
predict I call C LF not predict with the
test data the two-dimensional array of
the test features and I get back
when a missional array of responses if I
want to evaluate a model I can use this
score method which gets both the the
test data and some test labels this
tells me how well my model generalizes
to test data and this basic API is the
same for for our classification or
regression algorithms and they all have
this fit predict methods what scoring
does is basically it makes a prediction
and for classification it computes the
accuracy so how many of the predicted
labels are the same as
test labels and for regression it uses
the r-squared any questions so far okay
the other big class of models that are
very commonly used I think is
unsupervised transformations these are
models that create a new representation
of the data
one of the most classically one of these
PCA principal component analysis so here
I want to make model that creates the
first three principal components I have
PCA is implemented in a class that the
time to set any of the parameters of the
model is when I instantiate it so now I
have the specie I object which is an
instance of the PCA class we're set the
components to straight so extract as
three first principal components then
again I have a fit method which takes
the data array X train this is not
supervised models so there is no white
train or even if there was we would not
use it
so this stores the model so the
coefficients of the first three
principal components then I can apply
this model to some new data X test and
then I can use the transfer method to
get a new representation of the data
so here transform projects the data on
the first three principal components so
here's a summary of basically most
things that are important of the basic
API of scikit-learn so all the models
have a fit function or fit method sorry
where the first parameter is the data X
the training data and if it's a
supervised model there's also training
labels or training targets why there's a
predict function if you want to predict
something like the wide this is for
regression classification and also for
clustering where you want to get cluster
labels and there's transform func you
use the transform method if you want to
get a new representation of the data
so you transform your data X into a new
X this is for pre-processing
dimensionality reduction feature
selection feature extraction
I said alright so far selection means I
choose a subset extraction means I
create new features from your so for
example it's most commonly used when you
have non numeric data like you have
images and you want to have key points
or what we're going to talk about later
you have texts and you want to have a
backwards representation so future
extraction is going morph going from
your raw data to like the numeric
representation we want to work with all
right so the next thing I want to talk
about which is like essential to all
machine learning is model complexity or
like the concept of model complexity
which is also called by bias-variance
tradeoff I really don't like the word
bias variance like the term wise very
it's trade-off and I can explain in a
bit why not I wish I made that joke so
model complexity or overfitting and the
fittings who are who has heard of
overfitting here everybody ok cool
we're gonna explain it again so most
machine learning models have some tuning
parameters say how complex of a model I
want to learn for example and linear
models you have some l1 or l2
regularization in decision trees you can
decide how deep do I want to grow the
tree and something like that exists
basically in all models and so if you go
from simple models which is on the left
to complex models that's on the right
how accurate you can predict on the
training set in goes higher and higher
because more complex models mean you can
model data better and better and so you
can make better and better predictions
however if you look
and what happens on the test set on
generalization and new unseen data you
the accuracy arises with more complex
models but then there's some tipping
point where generation gets worse and
this is sort of where overfitting
happens you built a model that now fits
to the noise and train data focuses too
much on the very particularity on the
trail of the training data and learn
something that will not generalize to
the new data and so there's a sweet spot
in the middle and we want to find and
sort of if you in if you're in the on
the left-hand side of the figure you're
the under fitting regime your model is
too simple and you can usually see that
by seeing that training and test
accuracy are very similar if you do as
well on the test set as on a training
set that probably means your model is
too simple you should like do it a
little bit better on the training set if
you do a lot better on a training set
then another test set that probably
means you're overfitting because you
don't want the gap to widen too much and
so selecting the right model and
selecting the right parameters of the
model is what we do to find a sweet spot
and so now we won't talk a little bit
about the methods that we use to find a
sweet spot so the first thing we can use
is cross-validation just to evaluate
where are we on this curve so you can do
it's put your data into training and a
test set trying on a training set test
on a test set that will give you some
measure of how well you generalize but
it's not a very robust measure so a lot
of people want to do cross-validation
says put your split your data into K
folds let's say five trained on four
predict on the other one and repeat this
five times it's very simple to do this
since I could learn using the cross
vault
score it's one of the very few actual
functions that are not not classes in
scikit-learn
and so you you call a cross wall score
function with the model you want to
evaluate as the first parameter so here
it's a support vector machine the data
ax the labels Y and then some
cross-validation
so here just say five fold cross
validation so what is this is it does
the splitting has five iterations and it
returns the scores if I say CV equal to
five they will actually do stratified
cross-validation for classification by
default so if the SVC support vector
classifier is the classification task
and so this will do stratified
cross-validation which means it
preserves the fraction of each class in
each fold
so if overall I have like ninety percent
in Class A ten percent in Class B then
this will make sure that in each fold
there's 90 percent of Class A and ten
percent of Class B which gives you like
a bit more robust estimates there's also
other kind of cross validation methods
apart from cave walls and certified cave
fool there's shuffle split which splits
the data randomly and you can control
the number of iterations and test size
independently there's also things that
work with correlated groups for example
if you have data coming from several
patients and you want to generalize from
one patient to the other patients or
from one website the other websites is
called label k-fold and there's like ten
of them in scikit-learn and it's also
quite easy to create these yourself if
you have a particular correlation
structure in your data you don't need to
make sure that you respect the
correlation structure when you do cross
validation for example I should have an
image for this but if you have a time
series and there's a trend in the time
series now if you do k-fold
cross-validation with shuffle data you
will have completely destroyed a trend
so this means you will have points that
are close everywhere so your training
set will cover each area of the trend
whereas in reality sort of you want to
usually predict from the past to the
future and so you will not see the last
part of the trend going up so if you
have a time series or other correlated
data it's very
you have a cross validation method that
respects these correlations and actually
reflects how it will be used in
production oh yeah leave one like this
label one are the ones that workers
correlated groups okay so so cross
validation helps us to evaluate the
model but usually we don't only want to
evaluate it we want to find a sweet spot
and the way we do this is using word
search mode most of the models have like
a whole bunch of parameters here for
example the support vector classifier
has regularization see the type of
kernel and then like five different
parameters for the kernel and so we
don't want to tune them by hand we want
to use grid search to find a sweet spot
the way I usually want to try to run
grid search I usually run a grid search
is I start with my whole data set and I
split it into a training and a test set
then iron cross-validation on a training
set and do a grid search here so for
each parameter setting that I want to
try around cross-validation or a
training set and record a
cross-validation score then I use the
parameter setting that does best on the
in the cross-validation and use this
parameter setting for the final
evaluation on the test set so you can
see here they're sort of a nested scheme
I split my data twice basically you
could also do this by putting your data
in a training validation and test set
the crucial part is that you don't use
your test set to adjust the parameters
of your model imagine you have many many
parameters and you adjust them all on
the test set then maybe you have a good
result just by chance if you take the
best of these results you'll be way too
optimistic in how well you actually
generalize so you actually should use
your test set only exactly once so maybe
if you were did some competitions on
Cagle and you submitted a lot of results
and the leaderboard score went high
higher and higher he said oh my leaders
leaderboard scorers getting better and
better and then there was the private
leader board and you were like I know
places below of course you fixed you
tested too many different parameter
settings on the public leaderboards this
is the same principle so we want to only
use the test set this is like the
private leader board basically we want
to use this exactly once
all right
so the way to implement grid search with
cross-validation scikit-learn it's
pretty simple it's implemented in the
grid search class so as I said before
I've put off a test set before I run the
grid search so I can evaluate the
parameter setting I define a parameter
which is a dictionary that goes from the
parameters I want to adjust to the
values I want to try so here this is
like a logarithmic or exponential grid
so this goes from zero point zero zero
one zero point zero one zero point one
one ten and not a hundred so seeing
gamma are the parameters of the support
vector classifier so these are actually
the the parameter names and want to
adjust and so essentially the skirt
search with the classifier and a perm
grid the cool thing about a grid search
CV is it's what we call a Mehta
estimator so it behaves exactly like the
classifier which so it has this fit
predict and score it we saw before and
so it has exactly the same interface the
only difference is that it uses as we
see internally to and then finds the
best parameters so basically you can
totally forget about if you do a grid
search and just treat this grid as just
another classifier but when you call fit
where does is it doesn't run the grid
search and it finds the best parameter
set then it rebuilds the model using the
best found parameters on the whole
training set and then you can use the
test set pre evaluate and this will give
you like an unbiased estimate of how
well this classifier will do on new data
all right there is no validation set in
the cent I mean there's many validation
sets be course I do cross validation
right and so this is like I use all the
data that I have any other questions
about this oh yeah sorry
so you do use cross validation on a
training set so you you this is
relatively robust so yes you assume that
sort of it's the same for a Trestman
training set it has no training set
I mean you generally assume that the
training and test date they have the
same distribution otherwise you can't do
machine learning but sort of you try to
do this cross validation to not only
focus how what the training error is you
look at what is the like holdout error
on the training set using
cross-validation and then you basically
confirm how well does this actually
generalize to new data on the test set
does this answer the question kind of
okay can you clarify maybe
okay so the question is if you get the
best parameter setting why would it be
the best one also for the test set
because you assume your data is iid so
you later as a independent identically
distributed because it so all of
scikit-learn and 99% of machine learning
makes this assumption and if you don't
do some make the assumption that you're
training in a test data comes from the
same distribution you cannot learn
anything unless you or unless you know
how the distributions relate to each
other any other questions okay cool so I
want to go through a quick application
sentiment analysis so this will be on
the IMDB movie review data set so we
have texts here which are reviews of
movies like this one one of the worst
movies I've ever rented already had one
of my favorite actors on it Travolta in
a nonsense role and so on so on and so
we have label for this which is negative
so I'm I'm to be you have one two three
four or five stars here really only want
to classify the data into positive
negative so negative is 1/2 stars
positive was 4/5 stars and we threw away
three stars because we didn't know what
to do with it or the researchers that
assemble this dataset did that and so
the idea is given a new movie review can
we predict is this a positive review or
a negative review and we have a data set
of 12,500 positive reviews 12,500
negative reviews and the same for a test
set so obvious problem here is this
review doesn't look at all like the acts
that I wanted before I wanted a matrix
like with floating point with fixed
number floating point values to
represent my
each sample here each sample is like an
arbitrary length free-text the standard
method to go from free text
representation to numeric representation
that machine learning can work with is
the back of word method who here knows
the back of word okay so this is
implemented in the count vectorizer and
the tf-idf vectorize urns I could learn
so the basic idea is you start with some
string that you want in coach so let's
say my review is this is how you get it
ends the first step is to work it up
into tokens or words there's like
several fancy ways to do this it's like
a learner uses a very simple one we
basically split up by whitespace so we
have our sentence we split up by
whitespace we also lowercase it to
normalize a little bit then you go over
your whole data set over your whole
corpus say all the reviews we saw on the
whole training set and we built the
vocabulary this is basically a large
Dictionary of English words so sorry I
work to this and this is like usually in
the tens hundreds of thousands depending
on the dataset size then we go back to
the original string that we want to
encode and we count how often does each
of these totems appear out of these
hundreds of thousands of words only six
actually appear so there's a whole bunch
of zeros and six entries of one so
there's a one for n so one forget one
for how and so on because we don't want
to store all these zeros we use sparse
matrix representation to only store a
nonzero entries and now we have a fixed
length vector representation of integers
most of them are zero and we can use
machine learning on these questions on
that
why don't you make singular from plural
and one don't you make it singular you
can make it singular that's a bit more
tricky me and also maybe you don't want
you I mean you can also do stemming to
get like different verb forms and so on
and maybe I mean okay you using a porter
stemmer nearly always increases
performance I don't do this here for
simplicity's sake let's say you you can
use more advanced stuff with
scikit-learn you can give it your own
tokenizer so if you want to add even
more complexity and we already had you
can consider an only single works but
pairs of words so often you have
something like good and not good and if
you only count how many how often each
word appears the the negation of the
good gets lost and you only count
oh there's one good and the not might be
in a completely different like you don't
care whether or not this so instead of
looking only at single tokens you can
look at pairs of tokens basically so you
look at all two neighbouring words so
here what I get out is this is is how
how you you get get ants and you can do
this if you want until arbitrary length
usually want like two or three you make
sense more the feature space explodes I
mean this is a bit more or less maybe
not quadratic but nearly quadratic
increase the number of features all
right so we have back of word which you
can do unigram sand by grams and this is
how we're gonna represent our data so
I'm gonna switch to
a notebook working with text data can
you see this in the back yes okay so
there's a URL if you want download the
data actually didn't put the data in the
repository if you downloaded it because
my last conference everybody tried to
load this 500 megabyte data set at the
same time and then no one could check
out anything anymore
so there's like a load funnels function
it's I could learn that loads it helps
you load text data and so here I have a
text train which is just a list of
strings and white rain which is a numpy
array so white rain has 12,500 zeros and
12,500 ones so these are the positive
negative labels so zero is negative I
think let's check this and I also load
the test dataset and that's the same
size I can look at so this is test train
like it's the second training point and
okay you can see this this text there's
some Unicode in there
and you can look at the label here 0
which means bad review so words can't
describe how bad does move yes that's
probably negative review all right so
now we can use the count vectorizer to
convert this data from the rod strings
to the back of word representation so
you can't vectorizer as I said this is
what I would call feature extraction the
count vectorizer
is a transformer so I fit the model
using the data and then I can transform
it to your representation here
instantiating the model I fit it on a
trading data and now I check out how
large is the vocabulary it's 75,000
words I can also look at with
get future names I can look at what kind
of words are found so it found a lot of
value at the first fifty that's mostly
numbers and 1 p.m. and as your a.m. and
I don't know maybe not super interesting
if I look but later then I see a lot of
words with starting with pin now I can
and I said I can use a transform method
now I get a sparse matrix representation
and there's going to be one row for each
sample so there's 25,000 samples and one
column for each word counting often it
appears so there's 75,000 columns and
they can look at so I picked out one
training sample it's kind of short and I
can look out where there's non zeros in
this row and the matrix and if you want
you can figure out sort of the
correspondence of these nonzero entries
to the words I can also transform a text
test set in the same way and now I have
these two sparse matrix representations
and I can just learn a classifier so
here Linnaeus we see linear support
vector machine standard linear
classifier I called fit on the training
set and training data and training
labels I can look at how well it does on
the training data on the training labels
so you can see I do basically perfectly
on a training set and about 84 percent
correct on a test set so there's like
bit of a gap and doing basically
perfectly on the training set probably
means my model is a bit too complex
I pulled a function here to visualize
what a model learned I picked out you
can zoom does anyone remember how to
zoom out
so I picked 25 largest and smallest
coefficients in the linear model and you
can look at so red are are the 25
smallest coefficients so they correspond
to indicate being indicative of negative
reviews and you can see disappointments
worst waste truly unfunny but then you
also see things like crow Britney toy
screens which are slightly odd maybe
depending on your teen of Britney Spears
maybe and then if you look at the the
most indicative of a positive review you
see scariest through Fasching reeling
appreciated then and also things like
Kerry Australia squirrel so I mean this
kind of makes sense but maybe not
perfectly and that's probably like a
case of overfitting where we fit too
strongly to a training set I set the Z
parameter somewhat differently here so
much smaller that's much stronger
regularization and I can look at the
score and the coefficients again so the
score went out from eighty four point
five to eighty eight so test that score
improved a bit and now also the
coefficient let's make more sense i've
worst way stifle boring poor poorly so
maybe i should also prune poorly to poor
and disappointing a disappointment and
then the good ones are like excellent
perfect wonderful great amazing favored
loft and yeah
so question is why did I choose this
value of the parameter okay so what
about so I added the worst thing it's
how the thing I told you not to do with
just I test it on the test set so that
was my first mistake and so what I
should have done is do grid search over
see I I can guess this though because so
the linear support vector machine only
has a single parameter C was just a
regularization by default it's 1 and I
wanted more regularization which means I
need to decrease C so the creasing C 2
like Oh point one or point zero one or
point zero zero one would be like the
first thing I try I try to mention this
worked well I should have done at least
the split into test validation at sorry
training validation and test but I
didn't to keep it a little bit simpler
alright so far so good or any other
questions
all right so what we saw here is the
pretty like simple example of a centered
pipeline where you have some raw data
you do some feature extraction and then
you do some supervised model and the
curse this happens so often there's
something in second learn to help you
with building building these processing
steps which is called pipelines so yeah
as I said so usually you don't get
training data the way that you want to
feed it into your model you do things
like future extraction scaling and
feature selection before you pass your
data actually into the model and more
particularly make these more complex
pipelines is that often people then do
you cross validation and grid search
only on the final model which is pretty
bad because it means that all the
previous steps saw all the data so if
you do cross validation only in an last
step the previous steps all saw the test
fold and so you will get too optimistic
results that can be like very off so
what you should well she definitely need
to do is to do like cross validation in
the most outer loop and curse will eat
everything that happens after you get
your data and pipelines also helps you
with that
so what pipelines basically does is it
chains several transformations so here I
have t1 and t2 and then optionally I can
have Y and a supervised model or I could
have a clustering model or whatever and
classification regression is the most
common so what did when you fit this
pipeline what happens is you get your
input data ax new labels Y you fit the
first step to one and you halt you want
that fit then you have the first
transformation then you call t1 that
transform to get a new representation of
the data x1 use x1 to fit X to transform
the data sorry do it fit use x1 to fit
t2 and you transform your data using
each
to get x2 and then you give x2 to the
final classifier in what we saw before X
was the strings t1 was a count
vectorizer and then we built as far as
matrix representation and gave it to the
classifier and pipelines you can have
arbitrary a many of these steps and in
prediction you just use off the
transformers to transform your input
data and then do a predict on last step
so to go back to our text example so
here's a pipeline that does both the
factorization using current vectorizer
and the classification using a linear
SVC so there's as helper function make
pipeline just get the list of
transformer and the classifier this
again it's what I call the meta
estimator so it behaves just like a
classifier so it has a fit score and
predict methods and now what I can do is
I can give this to grid search and for
example actually properly adjust the
parameter see grid search with pipelines
works basically the same as with any
other classifier though you have to
specify in which step of the pipeline
you want to adjust your parameter here I
want to tune the parameter of the linear
SVC so I have to prefix the parameter C
with the name of this step in the
pipeline by default everything is named
by the lowercase class name so this is
the name of the step then there's a
double underscore which is just a
separator so that that's like you always
need to use this underscore double
underscore when you want to research
pipelines and then the parameter C and
that was pretty sure I used a different
version I'll say hit learn nevermind
yet this regard to warning
and then you can get best param so you
can use the grid search to make
predictions often you want to then
inspect the steps of your pipeline so
what I did here I want to visualize the
coefficients again so in a grid search
you can go to the best estimator so the
best estimator is the model that was
built on the whole data set using the
best found parameters usually so if you
only want to predict or score you you
don't need to access this you can do
predict and score and fit on the grid
but if you want to actually inspect
what's going on you can look at this
best estimator and this best estimator
is now the pipeline was the best sets
that was the best set parameter and now
can look at the steps of the pipeline so
here there's a name stats attribute in
the pipeline and so I look at the Linea
SPC step and I look at the contractor
risers step and so I got a feature names
from the contractor riser and the
coefficients from the from the model and
that takes a little bit so one of the
things that's happening here is so this
will build a new vocabulary for each
split of the data set into training and
or for each iteration of the
cross-validation to make sure that the
training and test parts are always
separated and which is why this takes a
little bit longer we can then also
search over parameters of the
pre-processing for example so here I
look at should I use only unicron so
should I use Gila grams and buy grams so
this is a parameter of the can't
vectorizer
which is called Engram range and gram
range is a tuple minimum range of
dopants I want to look at maximum
poking someone you look at so either I
just look at tokens of length one or I
look at tokens to look at single tokens
and pairs of toppings and so a great
search pose to see and this and all
right this will run for a bit but so
questions about grid searching with
pipelines or pipelines in general can
you actually make not one pipeline but
many pipelines and then compare the
performance of them in one shot
you mean for example I've searched
several pipelines basically or no I'm
just wondering like you said that every
action of your data processing should be
cross validated as well as yourself so
that means that if you change your steps
you would like to compare how like the
new step good compared to a previous one
so for example you did like some kind of
transformation of the data like a
logarithmic transformation then you say
maybe it's not logarithmic might like to
do other transformation and then you
want to validate them together like you
see how they different in performance so
can you do it in one shot or you need to
create different pipelines and then
basically if you really compare their
results currently the second hopefully
soon affirm mark so we want to be able
to search over different steps in the
pipeline but it's currently not possible
okay so the grid search didn't finish
that's too sad but if you want to do
stuff with text data like seriously you
should also look at NFC K which is a
natural language to a kid and a new kind
of replacement for it which is called
spacey definitely check these out where
if you want to work with a national
language data so actually I think I got
okay maybe I'll gonna ask you in a
little bit what you want to hear because
I have way too much material so one
thing I want to talk about definitely is
randomized parameter search so in the
grid search maybe a it wasn't very clear
in this you try all possible
combinations of parameters and you
repeat this for each split of the data
set so if you have two parameters that
each take five values as I said with the
support vector machine and you do five
fold cross validation so you have five
prep you have 25 combination of the
parameters and you do five iterations
over the data so you have 125 models
that you learn which is already quite a
bit and now if you add another parameter
with five values you have 500 no 624
models that you learn and so things are
kind of getting tricky so one
alternative to exhaustively trying all
possible combinations of parameters is
randomize parameter search which I want
to talk about now now so randomize
parameter search is actually there's
more to it than just sort of sampling
some parameters here is a figure that I
love from a paper by Bergstrom been Zhu
about why randomize parameter search is
awesome
so on the left you see a grid search so
we have two parameters the important
parameter which is on the x-axis and the
unimportant parameter which is on the
y-axis and you so the function you want
to maximize is this green function which
is like accuracy and the green function
it only depends on the important
parameter so you train not so you train
nine models here you or you run
cross-validation nine times for these
combinations of the three parameters and
so if you tried out three different
values of the important parameter and
you completely miss the the optimum now
with the randomized layout it just
sample from the important parameter the
import' and you sample from the
unimportant parameter and the important
parameter will have a different
because these are like continuous
parameters they will have a different
value each time and so you will actually
instead of having three values of the
important parameter you have nine values
of the important parameter so yet for
the same computational cost you get a
much higher resolution on what the
important parameter so this works very
well if you have a lot of parameters and
you don't know which one of them are
important and often in machine learning
you don't know what is really important
on this data set particularly we have
complex pipelines and so this randomized
layout can really help
there's smarter ways I want to talk
about in a bit but this is really a
competitive method so this actually
works quite well and so other benefits
are if you have continuous parameters
you don't need to choose a step size
we're like how many different settings
you want to try and decouples the run
time from the search space size so
before you try each point so depending
on how finally greatness and how many
parameters I have this gives me the
number of runs I have to do for the
randomized layout I can just say mmm I
want to run it until like 5:00 in the
afternoon and then I'm gonna stop it and
take the optimum and I get I will get
something meaningful them if I stop grid
search at some point I wouldn't have
explored the whole space and I won't get
anything meaningful and so we have the
most important part is if you act
Erewhon irrelevant parameters it doesn't
get slower if you add like five or LM
parameters to the grid search it will be
impossible to do if you had five
irrelevant parameters to the randomized
search it's still as fast so that's kind
of cool yeah so okay the slightly more
complicated example and what I thought I
had but so before basically we had
something like characterize their anger
arranged
we tried different parameters and then
we had linear SVC and we tried different
parameters and now instead of trying
these discrete values on the exponential
grid we give an exponential distribution
and we sample from this and it's really
like for what I showed in the last
figure to make sense it's really
important that you use a continuous
distribution if your parameters
continuous this is the exponential
distribution and that kind of models
this logarithmic grid and the way you
use it is exactly the same as grid
search Suvi just called randomized
search TV you give it here I give it a
pipeline for my text data and I give it
the parameter distributions so it can
either be lists if I have discrete
parameters or I give it distributions so
this is x1 is from Sify Farid stats
there's also like all the other
distributions and it just uses the our
RVs function of these and so give this
dictionary from parameters to two values
it from parameters the distributions and
NSL when the durations are one around
and the rest is just status in grid
search all right
any questions about this this parameter
too big yet so the question was why do I
use ex pon yes this is domain knowledge
so you still need to have like a prior
over what you expect the parameters to
be and if this is bad then this can go
bad
if I have no domain knowledge and I go
two slides further is there any
questions any other questions okay now
so there's sort of the more fancy
version of this which is called Bayesian
optimization for hyper parametric search
and so basically here what I show is the
figure from I think's experiment paper
where we use Gaussian processes to
search over hyper parameters so here
sort of the black function is what we
sorry
a black function is what we want to
optimize and so we start sampling a
point and at this point we see what we
are we have these two points where we
try to parameter settings and then we
saw how good the model s with these
parameter settings and then we fit a
Gaussian process through this which is
like the gray area that you see and this
models how hide a de value is but also
the uncertainty and you can use the
uncertainty to pick what is the next
best point to try and so sort of this
green function at the bottom I know if
you can see if it's green whether it's
called acquisition max this is sort of
the combination of uncertainty and
knowing the function value tells you
this is a good next point to try and
then you try this and sort of this will
give you a better model it will decrease
the uncertainty here it will give you a
better model of what the actual function
is and you can keep playing this game
and like propose new parameter settings
to try this doesn't need a prior slight
caveat though Gaussian processes usually
use stationary kernels which means that
if your thing is on a logarithmic scale
you need to search on a logarithmic
thing otherwise it won't work
but there's an extension of this to find
out if your model should be on a
logarithmic scale or an exponential
scale or a linear scale your parameter
and one of my students is implementing
that right now yeah yes yes the Gaussian
process makes the assumption that it's
continuous and it works best for like
continuous parameter settings yes
I mean it's if you have discrete choices
then the GP can't really do much else
than just try them out but for the
continuous parameters this makes actual
Ellison's though I mean you can do this
but the ragam I search actually is
pretty competitive to this the main
downside of the randomized search is
that you actually do need to know a good
prior so if we're lucky we all get this
in 0:18
probably easy 0:19 is more likely you'll
see so another thing that I want to talk
about for parameter search is you can
actually use do more efficient parameter
search for certain families of models so
to like because like the cost of
farmer's research is so big there's
tricks for some you can use so I don't
know if you're familiar with RF e RF is
records to feature elimination what it
does is it tries to find the least
important feature according to some
model and it eliminates that and it
doesn't recursively so let's say I want
to know or so the way this works is it
fits a little just a regression to a
data set and then it takes the
coefficient of lowest magnitude and
drops the future according to this
that's like unimportant tries again on
the new data set drops
next feature is unimportant then you can
ask yourself okay how many features
should I keep and you can run great
search to see how many features you
should keep and if I do this here
it'll iterate over all the parameter
settings so I do and features to select
let's say I start with and features -1
so it fits logistic regression drops one
feature fits logistic regression again
and scores it then I do and features to
keep n minus 2 it fits the logistic
regression with all features drops the
least important one fits elastic
aggression again drops the least
important and fits aggression again in
scores and clearly there's like a lot of
repetitive work doing things up too and
features -2 helps you to do it too and
features minus 3 so I mean you can just
go on doing it you don't need to start
from the beginning every time and so
doing great search like this is like
super wasteful so yeah don't do this
instead there's an object called air
fees are FEC V which has built-in
cross-validation and this just sorry
this just just do this for you so it
knows about the model and knows to logic
about how the models are built as a
function of these parameter and features
and so just scans through all possible
and features to keep and sorry and
features to select and it selects the
best value without any repetitive work
and so this principle can be applied to
a lot of models where different
parameter settings can benefit from each
other one very prominent example is LSO
algorithm for l1 regularized linear
regression where so what you see here is
this this axis here is more or less sort
of regularization strengths or alpha it
scales a bit differently but and the y
axis is just magnitude of a coefficient
and each color encodes a coefficient
so if you have a lot of regularization
that's on the very left you only have
like all your coefficients are 0 if you
start increasing the regularization the
read coefficient becomes nonzero then if
you start decreasing a regularization
the green coefficients becomes nonzero
and so on so searching and the nice
thing about lasso is that these parts
are all linear and you can compute where
the next step is so here you can compute
the model and also the score of the
model for all possible for all possible
settings of the regularization parameter
all that one's very efficiently and so
you can use the last of severe object--
to do this for you instead of doing grid
search and building a new model over and
over again and we have these CV objects
for many models now which allow you to
search over one or multiple parameters
very efficiently oh yeah here's a list
so linear models we have logistic
regression CV rich severe each
classifier last CV elastic net CV Lhasa
our CV lots of severe and so on the
feature selection airs RFA CV and for
trimming based models we actually have
none currently but we're gonna have
gradient boosting classifiers to be very
soon which basically selects how many
trees to add because you can iteratively
add more more trees and check how well
your model does which one I haven't
reviewed it yet so one of my students
wrote it I think it's done but I haven't
previewed it yet
oh actually this but the main downside
here is these don't combine well with
girth search so if you put them in a
pipeline and you want to put the
pipeline in a grid searched as bad and
it doesn't really work right now because
then the grid search will do a
cross-validation and this object will do
trust relation again then you have
nested cross
that you don't want to do and I hope to
fix that soon but so these are awesome
for use them on your biood themselves if
you put them into pipelines things get
weird and you should be aware and think
about what's happening then alright
we don't have that much time anymore are
you more interested in how to use
different evaluation metrics which is
one possibility
how do out of core learning this is
actually the two only ones oh but of
course okay the loudest people win
there's cool scoring function okay
there's a notebook on how to use scoring
functions you can look at it so out of
court learning out of choral learning is
doing learning with theta that does not
fit into Ram so I like to think about
three different scales for data Oh
actually so I want data that fits into
RAM they said it doesn't fit into RAM
but fits on disk and data that doesn't
fit on a single machine and so theta it
fits into RAM is sort of on my old
laptop so there's actually my new laptop
so my other laptop has four gigabyte of
RAM which is 1 million data points with
a thousand features that's already quite
big and I can learn on this in my old
laptop and if you get an easy to machine
from Amazon you can work on 68 million
data points with thousand features and
fit them all into RAM so who has more
than 68 million data points in this room
ok so you don't need out of core
learning you just need to spend $3 12
per hour and you can fit your data into
RAM and you don't need to do out of core
learning and that's actually it's going
to be much faster
and it's much cheaper than hiring a
back-end engineer you don't get a good
back-end engineer for 312 an hour even
if you have more data you can still fit
it onto disk and for 750 an hour you can
get six terabyte of RAM in SSD drives
and so if you you only need a cluster if
you have more than six terabyte of data
so but I can still tell you how to do
out of core learning so if you only have
four gigabyte of ram and you want to
work on a large data set with your
laptop because maybe you're not allowed
to use cloud computing because of data
privacy issues or something like that so
the way to do a core learning and second
learn is relatively simple there's a
function called partial fit that some of
the models have what partial fit does is
you iterate over the data and it
continuously improves your model if you
call the fit function on any model and
scikit-learn
every time you call the fit function it
will forget everything it ever learned
before so you can call the fit function
on iris and then you can call the fit
function and imagenet and we'll be fine
but partial fit means that you feed in
data and you can handle assume
continuously improve the model so for
example you can load chunks of data from
your hard disk or you can stream it in
over network you need to basically write
your own for loop and with each batch of
the data you call partial fit then the
end you get out a model so the supported
algorithms currently are STD classifier
STD regressor perceptron all these
linear models now face models mini-batch
k-means incremental pca mini batch
dictionary learning multi-layer
perceptron and the reference not null
release yet and all the scalars like min
max scalar and centered scalar and so on
and the way this code looks like
could be something like this so here I
sent she ate my classifier linear
classifier and I assume I have like ten
batches of data and I chunked it up
chunked UM's
in a way that
each batch fits into memory so I load
the data X patch and Y back from some
pickle and then I can call partial fit
on this batch I also need to specify so
what the classes are so the model can
allocate the right coefficients so here
does this like the digits dataset and I
have 10 classes from 0 to 9 and so I
trade over the first time batches and
then I can evaluate on 1/10 for example
for many of the models you want to go
over the mode data set multiple times so
STD classifiers is too rustic gradient
descent so after you write over data set
only once you probably haven't converged
yet so you want to make basically do
another outer loop to improve the model
further the only model where you don't
need this outer loop is naive bayes
naive bayes basically just counts and
going over the data set once will give
you the optimum solution oh one thing
that I have included here is it's very
there's a very helpful function or
option and pandas the CSV reader has
chunk size parameter which allows you to
read very large C's feed CSV files and
chunks so that's even if you have a CSV
file it doesn't fit into memory you can
read parts of it and iterate over the
parts one thing is also very helpful for
working with large text data sets is the
hashing trick so before we talked about
a text classification using Beco words
if we remember you get your string you
tokenize that you build a vocabulary you
do a sparse matrix encoding using the
vocabulary if you want to do out of core
learning this part is a problem for
example if you have streaming data you
can't go over the data set to build a
vocabulary and if you do out of core
learning maybe the vocabulary is so
large that you can't store it into in
memory but you can use the hashing trick
to kind of avoid this problem here
basically you remove replace this
dictionary of all the words that you
saw with just a hashing function and use
each of the tokens and you hash it and
this hash gives you an integer do you
limit it by doing MOT with some large
number and then you use this integer as
an index into the sparse matrix and put
a one there for each of the words that
you observe so here there this appears
so I apply my hash function do this I
get out eight hundred thirty two
thousand four hundred and twelve that
means I put or I add one in the vector
in the future representation at position
eight hundred thirty two thousand four
hundred twelve and this way I don't need
to build vocabulary and I can just
stream data and I can encode the data
without ever seeing or knowing
beforehand all the words this has two or
maybe one main drawback the main
drawback is you can't go back from this
to the words so if you build a linear
model on this before we plot it like oh
this coefficient means this word and
that's maybe that makes sense but
because it's hash basically you cannot
go back to the words so you get a large
feature vector and you have no idea what
it means because it's hashing you can
also get collisions so two words can
hash to the same value so they can
correspond to the same feature but it's
very unlikely that two words that are
both important for your task has to the
same value so that's usually not a
problem I think how much time do I have
ten minutes okay I think you want to
skip kernel approximations and gonna go
to new stuff in cycler
oh okay we have even okay five minutes
great I also have stuff on in this how
to build your own estimator that someone
asked me to add yesterday and then I
added it last night
but I can't do it okay so what's new in
0 17 0 17 came out last summer and if
you haven't caught up with it here's
what's new latent dirichlet allocation
which is a topic model it's a generative
model for text to extract like it's
similar to clustering but it gives you
for each document in a corpus tells you
how is this a mixture of different
topics and it's a million supervised
model so you just give it a bunch of
text you say look 400 topics and gives
then it gives you groups of these
hundred topics and which document
belongs to which topics there's also
this graphical model which as Tim Hopper
pointed out in recent talk it's the
worst way to explain any of this to
anyone
the does anyone understand will
understand this without knowing what
letting directly allocation is no yeah
good so we have we used online
variational inference if this means
anything to anyone
so this is very fast we also added a new
optimization for logistic regression in
richer regression called si G here you
can see a speed comparison so it depends
a little bit on which data set you're
working on but for very large datasets
and very sparse data sets this is very
good and it's basically faster than SGD
always and often faster than linear
which is the standard solver for
logistic regression
it takes more RAM than SGD but it's very
fast
we also have a new solver for then I
could have made your factorization which
is like a B factor ten or something I
get faster than the previous nmf and so
I could learn we have also a new
implementation of the Burnside
approximation for T's knee so it East
needs now like a factor of 50 or 100
faster and it was before we have also a
cool thing so I just mentioned this so
you can actually you can grid search
over different pre-processing z' for
your data if you use the function
transformer so function transformer
creates a transformer for you from given
function so maybe you wanna use a linear
model and maybe you want to know some of
the features you want to log or some of
the features you want to X or you want
to compute sin sinus or anything so
function transformer you give it any
function and it will create transformer
object for from this that you can use in
a pipeline we also added a voting
classifier which is basically just very
simple ensemble so you can give it some
classifiers and it'll average the
probabilities our question is is this
majority voting
there's voting hard and voting soft
working soft is arc max after mean
probabilities and heart is majority we
edit two scalar which are called so
these are for pre-processing and scaling
your data the robust scalar which uses
robust statistics so it uses the
interquartile ranges to scale the data
which is more robust than using standard
scaler if you have outliers and we have
max app scalar which scales the maximum
absolute value in your data it's very
helpful for sparse data so before we add
this min max scalar which scales data
between 0 & 1 and the you can't use that
on sparse data because it shifts to 0
basically the only way to scale sparse
data and not shift to 0 is this one so
it's like we thought about long and hard
how to scale sparse data and we came up
with this I added locks added links and
from the user sorry from the API back to
the user guide so each class has a link
here to the user guide which helps you
to navigate to dogs oh yeah this was it
before then for 0:18
one of two biggest things for 0 18s we
will have a complete rewrite of the
Gaussian process it will be much faster
and much more rich so it'll have you can
build up our cherry kernels and learn
their parameters this is the classical
mana Lua dataset or I think it's called
co2 data set usually and you can learn
crazy kernels like this we will have
neural networks and this will be just a
very simple multi-layer perceptron that
you can like if you think oh maybe a
neural net will do better matter my
random forest you can just replace the
class name and try to eat neuron that I
wouldn't use this for like serious big
data your Net Applications because we
don't have a GPU support so this will be
a lot slower than using things like
piano and caris and tensorflow so if you
actually like if you're serious about
deep learning don't useless
we will also will have an improved cross
validation interface that it's actually
not that interesting
and our we will have a faster PCA so in
the future we will switch automatically
between randomized PCA and non
randomized PCA and will like
automatically set suite parameters for
you and so this was runtime this is how
good the algorithm is and you can see
that sort of doing amnesty went from 25
seconds to somewhere around 0 seconds
with
out like oh no here sorry when - ten
seconds
and it still is accurate and labeled
faces in the wild went from here to
there and slow pretty much as accurate
by my book
it'll come out June 2016 so relatively
soon it'll have no math basically so you
don't need any linear algebra or
probability theory but I'll explain
basically all of scikit-learn
this guy's called the hellbender thanks
hi thanks for your talk and do you have
any plans of integrating so I could
learn with the distributed processing
framework so just spark or other
frameworks so basically parallelizing
the algorithm insights I could learn is
near impossible so you can rewrite them
on spark that is what mi lip does or you
can the thing that you can do is
parallelizing things like dirt search
and cross validation over a network and
there's the guys that data bricks I
guess or the smart people they did this
spark SK learn and that does that so
thank you I was wondering what the
rationale is for writing a neural code
from scratch instead of just wrapping
one of the existing libraries it's not
that hard to write it from scratch and
all the existing libraries either rely
on piano or tensorflow
and piano relies on CUDA and that's
basically yeah
so basically nearly every time I try to
Tianna on a machine had failed
so trying to pip install piano is tricky
and it's a very heavy dependency and if
you don't do use GPUs then you also
don't gain much I don't think you can
benchmark it but I don't think it'll be
faster think Andria's again